now anchovies are you can't eat
anchovies yeah
uh you can you do an anchovy
i'm not i i think fish should be banned
i don't care for fish strong words so
smelly
okay and really disagreeable to the
touch okay yeah
well so defend the answer because
there's nothing like yeah i don't
i i don't know that i have to defend the
entry in the sense i'm not i'm not
proselytizing i feel that as long as
those who like to eat anchovies can i
don't mind if those
don't in fact i don't like sometimes i
feel
you shouldn't you know it's very
difficult i am someone who does put
forks in people's mouths saying try it
so i'm trying to stop being that person
but i loved it
so i don't know who it was who said you
know the answers were the bacon of the
sea
and i do think there is something so
wonderfully uh
deep and they've got such a sort of
intense
sort of throaty saltiness which i love
and also you probably eat sanchevos and
doesn't know he's eating them because
they're in lots of things
they are in lots of things but if
they're cooked well and they're good and
you
start them off in the beginning and add
them to some onions in a pan or just
cook them in olive oil
they sort of dissolve into it and they
aren't salty or particularly fishy
but i think a lot for a lot of people is
just that but that's the thing about
fish people always say
oh but it doesn't taste a fish well then
i think what's the point
but but that's why i wouldn't try and
make someone i like saltiness
and i and i like that very intense
flavor marmite is salty yes but
fishiness
but if you went to someone's house and
they served fish
would you just poke it away what if it
was an anchovy that had been dipped in
marmite
would you go for that well i'd be
interested i'd be fascinated
yeah i don't know it's difficult every
pub you go into now stinks of fish
i'm furious about it i'm furious about
pretty much everything though well
they're shot now so cheer up